i'm richard
what's your name mayor give it up
for miss lady hawk herself
why didn't they call you lainey hawk i
made a shot in a basketball game
25 years ago you think you're a hero
boy i love it look at that it must have
been some shot
most places no around here
yeah what do you do there i'm a
detective
a detective you don't have any bodies
hidden under your porch do you
uh not yet no
[Music]
the east town police department received
a call reporting a dead body
in cretum creek get this out of a [ __ ]
you did this
cause if you don't i'll kill it myself
tell me about your father he was my best
friend
he passed away when i was 13. he was a
detective
at least you've still got your mother oh
we can't stand each other
i can feel it happening again
this expectation from people to be
something i don't think i'm good enough
to be
i know what you've been through
and i know you're worth saving
the ground is just falling out beneath
you mom we don't know what's gonna
happen all right
go back to the five dig deep recommit
yourself
doing something great is overrated
[Music]
because people expect that from you
all the time
[Music]
you